l tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo episodio di the world lo eravamo
rimasti non mi ricordo guardatelo scorso
episodio
buona visione potrei uscire venuto nella
mia piccola vede questo non me lo
ricordavo a non saper volare oppure di
questo videogioco
d'ora in avanti puoi contare sul mio
odio incondizionato
ah beh non sono io l'autore piacere di
conoscerti piacere è tutto mio
ma che anzi ha però e boogie
ammettiamo ipoteticamente che mi
avvicinassi nei pressi della tua ombra
dovrei temere per la mia incolumità
[Musica]
grazie per avermi rassicurato va bene
cervello ha finalmente trovato cosa
regalarti per il prossimo capito ma è la
bandiera nazista erano bigotta neo
avanti raga e non ho capi pianta che
arrivano mari qua che dovevamo tono con
distanze ci sono il suo posto troppa
roba veniamo prima vedere che cosa che
ci sono mobili che sono contento
giradischi nei paraggi leggi e la
madonna ma ricordavo sta roba
la horde line rocco softline 80 69 69
sta roba qua esattamente a che cosa
serve spiega mio vecchio berretto prendi
ci sono talmente tante robe con cui per
agire a mio marito potremmo sentirci
preso trovato dei capelli possono
sbirciare dentro il muschio
ok forse sta roba avrei preferito non
vederla prova bene più avanti
picasso parli del quadro o del camion
che si è beccato in faccia
posso passare anche posso entrare vabbè
simpaty ronald s'innervosisce sempre
quando busto mentre in bagno aprì la via
beato apriamo una cosa che la bat appesa
sulla maniglia più del martello di thor
chi non aprite quella porta prendere ed
vairo anche tolto la cravatta dalla
maniglia ma il punto della questione non
cambia
vabbè entriamo qua dentro raga non ho
capito cosa mi serve la cravatta che
perché torni a dovrei entrare nella
porta cosa quanta roba che c'è quando
entrò orinatoio come ritratto forse hai
visto troppe puntate di lupin iii ma
sono sempre convinto che dietro quella
roba ci sia qualcosa
ok ok decisamente non è una buona idea e
dagli del plutonio sento una strana
energia che mi spinge a fare cose che
non voglio ma resisterò a non posso
farlo per cadute una buona idea birra
usare tutto con tutto non funzionerà in
questa avventura e ti odio
c'è un miliardo di rob e fammi provare
almeno a far le cose non per le balle
poi c'è il simbolo di the sims scheletro
pala lo schema ascolta amico in questo
videogioco non c'è posto per due
scheletri non dire una parola o ti
faccio rimpiangere di essere morto ok
geniale questa è la geniale un bravo
ragazzo
bene tutto questo devo distruggere la
pianta carnivora sveglia vecchio la
povero ma perché non è che potrebbe
cucirmi dei capelli sulla testa di
questa bambola richiesto un po insolito
ma non vedo motivo per non assecondarlo
cosa mi sembra una bambola usate ceneri
non so cosa farmene mi ricordavo io devo
fare una roba del genere ma non mi
libero perché
troppo gentile bene da un'altra parte
io vorrei vedere cosa sono sti posti sul
punto non senso ciao d'orcia perfetto ho
trovato subito la torcia così come sono
tornata boogie man c'è ancora la mummia
di prima che sta facendo perché ci sono
delle ciambelle sulla brace questa mia
che non parla di prima infatti era un
piacere rivederla non parlerà neanche
adesso esatto è una torcia 60 90 book in
italiano buchi mente tutto questo che
devono adattare c'era le pile a
movimenti non so se schediamo aveva un
megafono era un bambino con un megafono
[Musica]
aveva proprio fregato non gli va
riconosciuto e anche ne aveva fregato
finto boogeyman tyler non mi voleva fra
i piedi e mi ha chiuso qui dovevo pur
fare qualcosa per tutto questo tempo
posso prenderla polaroid e quindi
presumo col tuo permesso prenderei
questa boogie fai pure te lo sei
guadagnato srotola perché of the dead
va bene e questo è da dove saltano fuori
sono le locandine di un concerto horror
billi che c'è stasera al vecchio
cimitero mi ha sbloccato un nuovo corso
la mappa quindi a questo punto andiamoci
assolutamente non ha idea di cosa sia
questo posto perché no
[Musica]
vedo cose teppistello share avanza tanta
ei ragazzi potreste prestarmi qualche
petardo
fateli comprare da tua madre la tua
madre comunque ragazzi anche io ad
halloween scopriamo i petardi quando ero
piccolo e non era un teppistello erano i
mini ciccioli però vabbè quella e non
erano nina volare quadro è vero
ciao non sono e sono ronald nonna non
riesco proprio a capire cosa dici provai
dirle che hai mangiato magari qualcosa
risolvi quello che ogni tanto spunta
dalla sua il nonno quindi posso posso
darle la dentiera adesso ecco perché non
riusciva a parlare
ronald tesoro di nonna sei venuto a
trovare tutto ci scommettete che adesso
mi dice che sono magro ma manchi
qualcosa sono vegano sarebbe davvero
troppo per lei no cosa combina una cosa
combina il nonno era veramente i giorni
ormai che tenta di uscire dalla sua bara
ha detto che ogni volta si dimentichi di
fare attenzione alla testa almeno ti
lascia un po tranquilla era ora non gli
è bastato tormentarmi in vita nemmeno il
tempo di morire che subito ha pensato
bene di farlo anche lui bastardo ragazzi
manca nota nati ma ronald si è
pericoloso là fuori è pieno di atei
prendi questa ricchezza
se solo ti dicessi che ho incontrato
gesù e giuda che giocavano a beer pong
non ci crederesti nonna di controllare
prima sto posto qualche l'ultimo che vi
rimasto e il mare e macchina del tempo a
per usarla devo parlare con lui e questa
macchina del vento a questa macchina del
tempo
sì anche se al momento è ancora un
prototipo sperimentale
se riuscisse entrai quale ok el amador
gelo zuma gol bach diavoletto tavolo e
tu esattamente chi saresti sono pan la
coscienza cattiva di questo piccolo e
miserabile uomo io volevo prendere l'eco
non rischiare di ritrovarmi un serpente
sotto la felpa la puoi prendere qualcosa
di stage o come iniziato grazie
non so non so davvero cosa dire a non
guardare mette il sogno di un bambino
che diventa realtà
e va bene navicella aliena guarda tu
stesso alla mia destra che io sia
dannato questo ci porterà un sacco di
soldi altro che il neolitico forza
andiamo abbiamo del lavoro da fare
di fatto la navicella regala no non mi
fate [ __ ] la navicella ok dov'è
andato se li metto almeno l'assenzio il
custode non mi sembra un tipo da
superalcolici cosa abbiamo messo potenti
l'ultima volta la birra semplice di
quanto pensassi qualche euro un'ora e
mezza
intanto è tornato indietro per tornare e
rimette va bene omaggi della casa una
bevuta non si rifiuta mai bene a vanga
così bravo dei diritti e la stangata
invoca bravo
così ko tra l'altro va bene
il terremoto non fissarmi in quel modo
non aveva altra scelta e poi non riesce
a svitare un po mordano dorme come un
angioletto le chiavi ascolta terra che
pirla sbagliato è spuntato pennywise che
veniva dalla discarica chiavi e 30
orologi perfetto adesso non mi ricordo
che cosa dovevo fare di preciso però
dovrò votare giurato l'armadio non ho
idea di come e cavi maledizione dei
pochi vantaggi della mia forma
scheletrica e che sono immune
all'elettricità bene perfetto e penny
wise che spunta tra discarica che è
veramente triste armadio e niente quindi
adesso che abbiamo fatto questo è un
manga che deve convincere lo zio a darmi
una mano a trasportarlo armati con lo
zio con la festa c'è un'altra fila
adesso si possono fare le cose tipo
questo potresti essere non lo so questo
lo potevo fare questo lo potevo fare il
consenso non lo potevo fare a il magnete
dovrebbe a questo punto funzionare che
si prospetta una pesca molto proficua
finalmente se queste sono le tue
aspettative di vita zio perfetto bene
non posso credere che tu ce l'abbia
fatta con quel buono poi ritirare un
premio scelta al chiosco della zingara
poco fuori città mi ha segnato nuovo
posto sulla mappa che a suo tempo aveva
da dare la bibbia gesù sopra vedere che
succede che però per farmela autografare
sarebbe bellissimo cioè firma copie il
duomo
quindi ragazzi concludo questo episodio
di the world rom continuano nel prossimo
episodio come al solito semplice quanto
mi piace anche lei solo che mi dà
notizia nei quali si chiede e ci vediamo
ad un prossimo armadio però almeno l'ho
tirato giugno e senza pestato un solo
fallo spostare e siamo a posto
in teoria
beh ragazzi
[Musica]